well mentality is super important um
yeah i mean hikaru exerts tremendous
psychological pressure on people because
you know that even if you're winning
he's going to put up an insane
resistance simo thank you
so your hands are shaking and stuff like
that's real
and um that is real and and and hikaru
knows this everybody knows this and
that's credit to him
he sets it up in such a way that uh you
know
it's even if you play well that's only
part of
it okay
[Music]
the games have become quite complex so
there are things i have to do without
full explanation
i explain everything after the game but
be prepared for some complexity we're
playing fan of 163 let's go with the d4
again
i've been playing a little bit more d4
and let's play with the london system i
know a lot of people play the london
and they want me to play the london as
well
so here knight c3 would transpose into
the jabba london let me play a job of
london because that is my main opening
and i actually want to show you guys
give you some of the ropes
of the job of london which is kind of a
cross between the jabba and the london
sorry kind of a cross between the
varisav and the london
usually in the classic london you play
c3 okay so e6 is already in inaccuracy
one of the good things thank you to the
specimen about the move knight city
where can this knight go
where which square can this knight leap
onto kind of like a fried liver
that's transposed to the other side of
the board yes
now the point here isn't to win the rook
but black goes 96 but now look at the
situation
the knight on a6 is stuck and it's very
hard to get rid of the knight on b5 with
a pawn
so now we're just going to develop our
other side
and we're going to play this london
style we're going to safeguard the pawn
so let's go c3 let's make sure this pawn
on g4 is very securely protected
well i'll explain so where should this
bishop go d3 or e2 what do you guys
think
uh and actually either square is fine
but what seems to be a little bit more
active yeah so d3 is a little bit more
active we just have to be careful
yeah so if we castle we blunder a piece
because he goes c4 he disattaches the
knight from the bishops how should we
support this knight
in order to make sure that it's safely
defended and when i say that that's a
key word for supporting it with a pawn
pawns are the best defenders of a piece
so we've already formulated that
principle
and here's what we have to be ready for
we have to be ready to sacrifice the
pawn on b5 and i'll explain that fully
after the game
but um he can pressure that knight with
this queen
let's drop our bishop and we will not
move the night we will let him take it
okay he takes it immediately
okay and he's yeah so this is an
interesting moment
now this is kind of what i mean we can
simply give that pawn up on b5 and we're
going to have
a good amount of compensation but um
because of the way that he's done this
we can also defend with the bishop a4
that's a little bit awkward though
but here's what i want to do i want to
give this pawn up
yeah rook takes a7 is very interesting
by the way let me think about how we
want to do this for a second
um
this is interesting we have several
tempting moves here
yeah let's yeah so let's play b6 and the
purpose of this move
is to force his knight onto a8 which
buys us more time we sacked upon his
knight now has to go back into the game
and in the meantime we're going to
complete our development we're going to
start putting pressure on his king
and perhaps combine that with pressure
down the a file that's going to be the
ultimate goal here
so yeah rook takes a seven is super
interesting okay
yeah this guy is playing extremely well
as well so let's centralize our night
the toaster thank you for the prime
let's centralize our night and i'll talk
about
various options after the game various
alternatives right it's hard for me to
talk about alternatives
because of the time that it takes night
he activates his knight
and now um we yeah i actually
played this really really well i i'm not
entirely satisfied with how white has
played this
yeah so so let's let's go for it let's
go g4
we have limited time before he brings
his pieces to the queen side
we need to use this time to start
attacking knight d7 is another excellent
move
um so ap ap wing thank you
okay damorax i don't want okay queen f3
let's bring the queen in
i want people to give themselves a
chance if you don't give yourself a
chance to understand things you're not
going to understand yeah this is too
high
that's the point of the speedrun i'm
trying to explain everything in a way
that will make it understandable for
everybody
okay so what should we do here how do we
continue
putting pressure on his position
now there are several ways of going
about this notice that the a file is
what he wants to eventually get his
pieces on
so before we do anything let's go rook
a1 to make sure that
the a file is at least under our control
if he goes b3 we can drop the bishop
back to and then
we're gonna go e4 and break apart the
center
and try to create more chances so let's
go e4
and uh yeah no this guy is just
extremely strong
now we need to keep tightening the
screws
now we need to keep tightening the
screws what does that mean
how do we bring pieces into the attack
yeah i don't
i mean we might lose this game manjaro
black thanks for the prime let's go rook
a7 let's bring the rook into the game
let's bring the rook into the game and
uh we have a lot of pressure in return
for the pawn i'm not entirely happy with
the level of that pressure but what
we're trying to do here is play on both
sides of the board we're trying to put
pressure on the queen side and put
pressure on the king's side
and the hope ultimately is that his
position at some point starts to buckle
but it's my position that's starting to
buckle not his because of the precision
with which he's playing this
so let's play how should we do this what
should we do
well if we play pawn takes he's going to
go b3
so this stuff is just not looking great
let's actually go e5 to lock things up
in the meantime
well i mean so now let's take it
and now let's get the rook to b7 attack
the bishop get it out of there
and um yeah we're getting soundly
yeah i'll explain why i'm like
in trouble here but now we're gonna
bring the queen to b1 ultimately we're
trying to get the queen to b5
and the point of that is that he has
pieces now on the seventh rank which
we're trying to attack
guys again tone down the accusations i'm
capable of losing a game
this guy just might be very strong you
know
i'm good with checking people after the
game but
as i've explained many times we want to
tone down the
baseless accusations particularly since
he blundered a bishop here
particularly since he just blunted
bishop but he could follows this up very
well he's going to capture d4
so we have to bring our rook back to b7
the same rook and now what we need to do
is we need to tone down his initiative
here
how should we do that well we can take
on h7
but then our bishop is going to be
stranded okay
so actually white is still in trouble
believe it or not we got to bring our
rook away
so that our queen is able to protect the
bishop
and not protect the rook at the same
time
okay now we're going to go rook b8
and force the trait of rooks if he takes
on c2 what do we do
do we take back on c2
yeah he's playing so president rook
takes f8 first no yeah queen takes c2
now
what what is the battle gonna revolve
around he has two
yeah this i mean he's got two of these
past pawns which are super dangerous we
need to use our bishop and our queen
to somehow limit the progression of
these puns
um and we also got to create counter
play so we're going to repeat moves here
really quickly
and we're going to try to induce g6
if he goes g6 he weakens his position
and then we're gonna use our pawns to
try to shatter
the defenses around his king okay i
should probably take the draw here but
let's let's push our pawns out for now
yeah this is probably a draw
realistically but we're gonna see what
we can do in terms of playing for a win
okay let's repeat moves again let's try
to bait him into
going for the win now let's go bishop e3
to attack his queen let's see where he
wants to put that queen
what i'm gonna try to do here is
establish a blockade
so okay that is oh my god that's
actually a really nice move
wait no i think i can take and now we
need to bring our king and i'll explain
all of this after the game guys do not
worry please do not worry i will ex i
promise i will explain
everything i'm doing you just got to
give me some slack here because i've got
30 seconds now what i'm going to do here
he's already made a mistake
he's going to lose his pawns how how am
i going to reach his pawns here
what am i going to do to reach his funds
what is it what is the next move going
to be
what yeah bishop d4 winning is pawns
winning his pawns boom there's one pawn
now we can we just take the second bun
in the game is over we're simply up a
piece
and now what we have to do is simply
bring our king up and induce zugsvan and
create a pass pawn that's kind of
the method that we've been talking about
that's it we're just going to bring our
king up and then create a pass pawn
and promote this path spawn using our
extra bishop as i always warn you guys
be very careful about pre-moving
in these types of situations so how
should we go ahead
how should we go about actually
promoting do we even need the bishop
here do we need to use the bishop
no g7 and then king f7 yeah and then we
promote
and now we can just go bishop f6 and
force his king back
and then deliver the checkmate yeah
guys not my first time getting into time
pressure trust me
um so let's talk about the game i want
to make one thing very very clear
uh and i'm gonna as always i'm going to
be honest with you guys about
what i feel which i think people perhaps
may appreciate in the end
now i am honored to do this because of
the feedback that i get which is so
positive and it's incredible
but i want and i'm no one to lecture
people about
mentality or or how to approach this but
i have
been in your shoes once i was in 800 and
i was a 1700
and i have listened to many a lecture by
gm's where i was completely over my head
uh and i totally get it but um i want to
encourage people to come in with not
with the attitude of
ah he's 2200 i'm not gonna understand
any moves this is way too fast
rather i want people to say okay perhaps
this is too fast in the moment
but i'm still going to be engaged i'm
still going to try to understand and i'm
going to ask questions
uh and not be afraid of that because
that's the kind of community we're
trying to set up here where anybody can
ask anything
uh and i will do my ultimate best to
explain this to the level that you're at
and nobody should feel bad for being the
rating that they are
that's the assumptions that i come in
with a speedrun even at this level so
this is where i'm going to explain
everything and i want people to at least
give themselves a chance and give me a
chance to help you understand stuff at
your level
thank you madigan for the prime okay
so this was the london system now knight
c3
is the job of london the classic london
is c3
which creates a stronghold on d4
oh my batteries i'll have to replace
headphones
and um we then get the bishop in between
the triangle
so i won't delve too much into the
theory of the london the move knight c3
really made a resurgence like five six
years ago
uh thanks to the efforts of this
georgian grand master bahadur java he's
sort of
very very flamboyant creative player and
i actually picked this up at that time
as well i've been playing this as one of
my full-time openings
since then now some people might look at
this and say well wait a second
can't i just take on c5 yes you can that
is a very legitimate line
black can pick this pawn back off you
can play queen a5 queen c5
or black can play e6 and um or black can
even play knight c6 and try to prepare
e5
the battle revolves around whether white
will be able to keep the pawn
on c5 black gets further control over
the center it's a very interesting line
now a lot of people here go knight c6
which is a horrible mistake
why is this a big blunder this is one of
the appeals of playing the jaba
at in blitz you will get a lot of people
even at a very high rating playing this
move
and the reason is and it's very funny
knight b5
black has no defense against knight c7
short of moving the king which is
horrible and if black goes e5 to
intercept the bishop
thank you mr tambes we take on e5 and
now
white is up one pawn but there is a
beautiful
idea that picks up a second pawn how
should you see this well this is a
forkable square
i've talked many times about the
importance of detecting forkable squares
squares on which a fork can be delivered
well what's stopping our knight from
coming to see it's the queen
can we distract the queen somehow well
we got to consider this move
and it's not the rook that we're going
after it's the queen we're up two puns
black's king has lost it's castling
right black is basically lost in this
position
so e6 is also interesting by the way yes
queen takes d5 is something i want you
guys to remember
but our opponent played e6 um a6 here
would be
a good move stopping knight b5 that's
actually one of the main moves
now an ip596 so as i explained
the knight on e6 is almost permanently
out of the game
uh and that's what makes this a
difficult position to play for black the
knight on b5 on the other hand
is occupying very nice and not really an
outpost
but a good square it can be supported as
we did in the game by a pawn
keeping the knight out of the game so
knight f3 bishop b7 just developing
going c3
uh buttressing the spawn on d4 that's
kind of a london move now bishop d3
putting the bishop in between the
triangle
so it's still like it has the contours
of a london
except there's this like knight on b5
which is an interesting flavor so bishop
d7
why is a4 important because if we castle
he goes c4 attacking the bishop
attacking the knight
so we need to defend the knight with a
pawn
c4 bishop c2 and he takes which i
actually kind of underestimated
takes a knight c7 so a lot of people
here suggested the move rook takes a7
which is a very interesting sacrifice
the idea is to get the rook to a
forkable square now you go b6
attacking the rook attack black and move
the rook here and we take the knight
let's say with a pawn
but the issue is i feel like white
doesn't have enough compensation white's
initiative is gonna
is gonna fizzle out because you're not
gonna be able to retain this pawn on c7
for example
if you were to now castle how would
black go about
winning this pawn and think of it in
terms of its defender like the bishop is
defending the pawn can we intercept
this bishop's control of the pawn thank
you siva for kimana chess
yeah bishop d6 good job guys and then we
win the pawn and black is left with an
extra exchange so it's a tempting move
but i don't think it really works
um so
maybe i should have just bit the bullet
and gun bishop a4
now i know that the bishop is passive
but at least we keep the pawn protected
and so is the knight the knight is also
passive
i decided to play the move b6
the idea is not only to double his pawns
and open the a file and i feel like i'm
more
poised to control the a-file than he is
but also we keep the knight out of the
game which gives us some time
to orchestrate attacking chances on the
other side of the board this should make
sense to everybody
but our opponent played this super well
b5 is a really good move
two ideas preparing to break down our
pawn chain and
preparing to deploy his knight to b6
why doesn't black take with the queen
because that would lose the protection
of the knight we would win the knight
okay castles b595 centralizing the
knight and here we played a move that i
know confused a lot of people g4
how do i know that it's okay to weaken
the king side like this and what is the
even the idea of g4 what exactly we're
trying to accomplish well from a logical
perspective
what we're trying to accomplish is get
this knight out of m6 what does that do
well imagine he makes a random move and
we chase the knight out of f6
when we chase a piece out of a
particular square the way we need to
approach that is ask well what
squares are now available to our pieces
so if we ask that question in that way
what do we find
h7 is weak that's an important
observation but what specific square can
we go to now
with one of our pieces and he has no
longer any defenders
yeah boom well g4 is true but h5 is more
effective because we attack
both pawns he's got to go g6 now we can
stack on g6
and he has no good way of defending him
that's how quickly things can crumble
here for black
because he's got no pieces in the
defense so that's actually the idea of
g4
but obviously pushing a pawn out in
front of your own king is not something
you should do lightly
and how do i know that he can't exploit
this well there's two things to bear in
mind number one
it's not like he has that many pieces on
the king's side
if he had a rook on g6 if he had a queen
on h4
it would be a different story but he
doesn't moreover i
have a lot of beef on the king's side
and remember these pieces can be
attacking pieces but they can also be
defensive pieces they make it hard for
black
to do anything in relation to our king
you know
that's like okay bad analogy but you
know
you know now nowadays in in the days of
zoom you wear sweatpants
you know to meetings where that would be
unthinkable just a year before
or you don't wear pants at all or you
know you
don't take a shower you don't brush your
teeth and you hop on like a super
important call with your ceo
and think of it that way it's not
inherently bad
to weaken your king if nobody's going to
see it and black can't take advantage of
it so
you shouldn't think of things globally
ah i'm weakening my king i can't do that
rather you should ask is it okay to
weaken my king can black exploit this
realistically in the future thank you
amba hopefully um
that analogy wasn't too far out there
but it'll help people understand
okay um yeah 94 is possible
and that actually is what black should
prefer but we can still go queen h5
we can still go queen h5 or we can go h4
followed by f3 try to chase the knight
out of there yes 94 would be the best
move but i'm trying to illustrate a
concept here
not necessarily analyze this position
directly okay
so i hope that makes sense he goes that
fd7 we get the queen into f3
knight ft7 another really good move
trading the knight
and g5 is no longer possible that
blunders upon so queen f3
takes takes knight d7 we got to move our
bishop back and now he plays b4
and now i played the mover okay one
which surprised a lot of people like it
didn't i just say that we want to attack
on the king's side why am i all of a
sudden
switching gears and attacking the queen
side well again you have to be very
flexible point a
and point b it's actually very hard
because of the way that he's defended
this
to make anything happen on the king side
i can't play g5 i can't play h4
and it's just too slow and i can't get
my queen to any of the squares
where it will build a battery with the
bishop so in the absence of that
you might as well try to attack on the
other side of the board remember that i
played b6
sorry i need to grab different
headphones so
let's get back to the game so does that
make sense we go over okay one remember
that i played b6
and i partially played this move in
order to open up the a file because i
thought that one day i might want to
exploit that
okay and here we're exploiting that
we're getting the rook to a1
and this is a very advanced concept
called attacking or
playing on both fronts when you're
fighting a war you want to open up a
second front because our opponent has
allocated some resources to the king
side
so logically it should make sense that
we're also trying to involve the queen
side
um well g gm zoot asks well why not
prepare h4 because that takes a lot of
time
that takes just too much time like you
can do this
and by the time you do that remember the
three move rule if an idea takes three
moves or longer it's usually unrealistic
guess what black's just gonna go after
our c3 pawn
by the time you do play h4 your entire
position is going to collapse
and it's not like when you play h4 black
just resigns
it'll take you a lot more time to
actually create threats
so it just takes way too much time okay
so yeah taking on b4 is possible but
then we break up our own pawn chain
i just didn't want to do that so we're
k1 so he takes and goes b5
and now we go e4 we're trying to attack
on both sides of the board yeah so a lot
of people asking about e4 e4 is fine
maybe that would have been good but he
has knight f6 much like in the game
and in and of itself e4 is actually not
going to like win the game or anything
he defends
everything here if we go g5 he takes on
e4
this leads to a mass trade and he can
slam his queen into d5 he's traded a
bunch of pieces he's up a pawn
and there's nothing left of white's
attack we cannot afford
to give up our light square bishop that
is the main vehicle or king side attack
so i wanted to play e4 at a better time
this is a better time
because he also has to worry about the
rope getting into a7
and that's exactly what we did he plays
b4
and that was a really good move um
because he's not
he's ignoring uh phantom threats there's
actually no
specific threats and he continues the
attack i played e5 to open up my bishop
chase's night away
knight d7 takes takes and now rook b7
trying to get his bishop out of this
active square
and queen d1 was a really good move
actually queen d1 was a really really
good move if he played b3
oh you mean here if he played b3 we
would have just gone bishop b1
and that's another good reason to play
rook a1 if we had played bishop b1 with
the rook on f1 we would not have been
able to get it there
okay so queen d1 was a really good move
okay and this demonstrates
my ability here to be flexible because
the queen on f3 was once good but it has
no more utility on this square
because it can't get into any of these
squares it can't get to h5 because we
can't play g5 that would blunder upon
so we need to find a new job for the
queen we can't afford to let it just
marinate on f3 and the job that i found
for the queen
is twofold first of all to set up the
battery with the bishop
that's not too bad that's worse than
having the bishop behind the queen but
it's better than nothing
and the other thing is we keep the rook
on b7 and this rook kind of binds him to
the seventh rank
does that kind of make sense so i'm
switching gears here to the queen side
and i'm basically trying to get the
queen maybe even to b5 and he panicked
he bought us the bishop and what should
he have done here
he should have probably prepared how can
he prepare an iba
what are the possibilities for black to
prepare an ipa what kind of things could
he have done here and i already think
that black made a mistake somewhere this
is getting
very interesting yeah rookie a would
have been possible but i just discovered
that against rookie eight
on the subject of flexibility what nasty
little move does white have
what should you notice here two pieces
on the same diagonal
that should ring some alarm bells and
white can go bishop a4 and skewer it
and the rook has to go to d8 now you go
queen b5 and black might lose a beast
anyway
so this is um this is quite unpleasant
so i think that maybe black made a
mistake
by by going no i just played this very
well i think i managed to create chances
maybe rookie 8 here i don't know i don't
want to delve too deeply into that
but at some point i created chances he
responded very well
and the situation is still super
complicated because he's got these two
connected passers
my pieces are scattered all over the
border my king is kind of weak
so first of all we have to drop the rope
back because if we do just about
anything
he's going to take c2 and then take b7
so the queen is overloaded we need to un
overload it now we go back to b8
trading is good we're up a piece takes
takes takes
and in this position white should be
better but it's very hard to contain
these pawns yeah i'll check the accuracy
after i finish analyzing for sure
and basically his mistake let's fast
forward to his mistake
his mistake was to go queen d5 and i
want to make this very
important point bishops are incredibly
good at containing past funds
thank you x3m coffee knights are
horrible containing past pawns bishops
are amazing at it
so it's very easy in your brain to
underestimate you think oh look at these
puns
these puns are going to steamroll him
guess what the bishop is a really good
blockader of past ones
and in combination with the king because
these pawns are not supported by black's
king
they don't have a chance we should have
what he should have done here is
something like queen b5 or queen a5
and he should have tried to use his
queen to supervise the progress of these
months that basically would have forced
me
i think to eventually go for this
perpetual
yeah so usually the bishop is much
better at containing passports than
knights
ippo makonochi and i'll show you guys
why that's the case and i'll show you
guys an example of this after we finish
analyzing
so basically he goes c3 but basically we
just put our bishop
on d4 at the right moments the king
blockades the pawns from behind the
bishop in front
and the pawns just go down one by one if
he didn't go c3
we would have still blockaded the pawns
of bishop d4
and then brought our king up and then we
can just ignore those pawns we can
circumvent them if he had gone g6
then i would have gone h4 h5 trying to
break up
the pawn structure around his king so we
can actually go for an attack here thank
you you monfil with five gifted to the
community holy smokes
yeah so g6 is a hook and what i want you
guys to understand is that even though
we only have two pieces left
the nature of chess is such that
even two pieces a queen and a bishop can
definitely create
very strong attacking chances against
the king particularly since he's still
down a piece
so does that make sense does it make
sense that when i do this
black's king side is really weakened so
what may happen
is a check like this guess what
checkmate ladies and gentlemen that's
how quickly things can deteriorate when
the king is this weak
even a very limited amount of material
can contribute to an
immediate attack there is even several
books on end game tactics
there's a very famous called von
pierlo's endgame tactics big big book
thick and it's a correspondence player
who compiled
i would even go so far as to thousands
of instances of attacks
checkmates and tactics in the endgame
there was an old russian coach or
steverkin i am who said
end games are 99 tactics that's what
people don't always realize end games
are incredibly tactical more so than
it might appear if you just go from the
number of pieces left on the board
right well if he forces a queen trade
then that's great for us because we're
up a bishop
and we can blockade the pawns now just
very very quickly before we move on
yeah queen takes e5 would defend but
again i'm trying to illustrate the
general
theme here not the specific position as
much thank you akilah for
linking that now the thing with knights
and pass pawns bishops can
stop a pass pawn from a very long
distance so let's examine
a concept here so let's say we have this
right we have a
a sample position i know there's no
black king we don't need it
we have a bishop and a knight and we
have an a pawn that is passed
thank you t556 which of the black pieces
should we use
to blockade to stop the progress of the
pawn
the answer is the bishop why
because the bishop can do it from e4 and
the great thing is this bishop could be
relaxing on a beach in hawaii it can be
it can be visiting the museum of modern
art while it's
while defending the pawn on egypt
because the bishop is a long-range piece
and the bishop most importantly is
unassailable white's king
can go back to the bishop ha ha joke's
on you
and this is not a very efficient um sort
of
this is not a very efficient path that
they can take so you can buy yourself a
lot of time
by guarding the pawn of the bishop now
let's say we were to remove the bishop
from the board
let's literally it's gonna knight's
gonna count to the bishop
and let's say that we use the knight to
guard the pawn
well you guys can all appreciate how bad
the knight
is right the knight is limited to this
square
and once the king approaches the knight
has no choice but to go into the corner
and the king literally traps the knight
that's it
there have been many games that have
been decided precisely in this way
you can even sacrifice you can leave
your opponent with
a knight sometimes even two nights your
car won't speak me like that in a very
nice fashion
and the knight won't be unable to
contain the extra to contain the past
pawn
for a long period of time and um
obviously if you were to move the pawn
to like a3
the knight would fare a little bit
better you know the knight would be able
to
to contain the pawn but the king could
continue to chase it and
you would have a draw because if white
plays a4 the knight can give itself up
for the pawn so barely the knight can
contain it
at its own cost but you guys get the
point knights are very bad at stopping
past pawns
comparatively speaking particularly to
bishops and of course to rooks
okay now don't take this to heart i mean
there are exceptions to the rule
um there's specific positions where
there are complicating factors
and and i want to make that very very
clear so for example
we can set up the following position and
this is a this will present to you guys
a complicating factor
for example here right here if the
bishop
tries to stop the past pawn what
resource will white have
who can tell me
you guys should be able to see the whole
board
resource is d5 and that's the mentality
you should always have right you should
be looking for
specific factors that may influence the
application of a particular theme so
here for example the knight might be
better off stopping the pass spawn
and the bishop might be better employed
as the defender of the knight if that
makes sense the king can't attack it the
bishop the pieces should work together
in this way
thank you snapple facts for the prime
but that's the concept on illustrate
okay now let's check the accuracy
and then we'll move on to the next game
tag team absolutely
so let's analyze my accuracy was
probably quite low but let's see
dr lodo 21 months holy smokes day girl
okay it was oh that was 96
for us damn girl 96
to 87.3 okay we'll take it
so it was 96 for us to 87.3
no that mean we you know i'm trying
these this
we're not just i'm not fooling around
with these moves this is what i actually
am thinking
okay um that was better than i expected
but let's go back to the speed run thank
you so much j
moses 10 gifted damn girl 100 bits on
damn mark art thank you guys really
appreciate it
87.3 is really solid and tactics don't
the accuracy doesn't reveal
everything um no td 97 non-best moves on
purpose is absolutely not what i'm doing
there are occasions when i do that to an
extent but i try to limit that
let's go on any questions about the game
or may we proceed
um
okay in your game with black pawns on d3
c45
uh so d4 my friends
um no because
let's see well d4 i can just take it and
stop the pawn on my king he just doesn't
have time for it because
my king is close enough to the pawns if
that makes sense let's go
[Music]